[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und christian sievers
in allen guten abend das war kein
fernsehstudio es gab keinen der
moderiert hätte und dennoch wirkt die
generaldebatte im deutschen bundestag
heute über weite strecken wie ein tri l
von den dreien die ins kanzleramt wollen
nur dass auch noch die aktuelle
amtsinhaberin mit dabei war ein quartett
also im hohen haus mit angela merkels
wohl letzter bundestagsrede bei der wohl
letzten parlamentssitzung vor der wahl
zur situation in deutschland ist die
überschrift aber dann ging es weniger um
inhalte als um wahlkampf wie karl
hinterleitner zeigt
nicht oft hat die kanzlerin sich zu
ihrer nachfolge geäußert und nicht immer
waren alle ganz sicher ob die
unterstützung für armin laschet wirklich
von herzen kommt zweifel die merkel
offenbar zerstreuen wollte er lob für
laschet konnte heute deutlicher nicht
sein
[Applaus]
bundesregierung mit armin laschet als
bundeskanzler
[Applaus]
verlässlichkeit maß und mitte stehen und
das ist genau das was deutschland
es war fast wie ein machtwort der
kanzlerin
unbeeindruckt davon aber der vizekanzler
eine attacke auf ihn er habe geschimpft
als versuchskaninchen bezeichnet konnte
olaf scholz das sei nur ironisch gewesen
und erreicht dabei noch salz in die
wunde der union
wir müssen dafür sorge tragen dass wir
sie überzeugen indem wir das machen
lockergelassen auch mit witzen über die
auf vielen veranstaltungen gelacht wird
wenn einige nicht lachen wollen und
darüber sich aufregen hat das vielleicht
etwas damit zu tun dass sie beim blick
auf ihre umfragewerte wenig zu lachen
haben
scholz mit seinem bewährten
erfolgsrezept er leise ruhig und
aufgelegt armin laschet dagegen in
angriffslaune mit einer klassisch
konservativen attacke auf den
sozialdemokratischen rivalen
gehört in den dank an die
bundeskanzlerin natürlich auch gedanken
dass sie in diesen 16 jahren zwölf jahre
gut auf die sozialdemokraten aufgepasst
hat das war eine große leistung
ich fürchte wenn nicht mehr die union da
ist wenn sie nicht mehr an den kanzler
vor sich haben der auf sie achtet dann
werden sie wieder schulden machen und
dann wählen sie wieder steuern erhöhen
wie wird es von ich kenne
die botschaft der grünen chefin bair
doch dagegen ging an cdu und spd beide
hätten versagt das zeige sich daran dass
sie acht jahre als große koalition
dieses land regiert haben in einer zeit
der vollbeschäftigung der guten und
sprudelnden steuereinnahmen niedrigster
zinsen und einfach diese chance nicht
genutzt haben sie haben es vermasselt
auf gut deutsch den weg zur
klimaneutralität endlich einzusteigen
für die afg hat die regierung in allen
bereichen komplett versagt bei der
energiewende der europapolitik der
migration oder auch corona
seit anderthalb jahren betreiben sie
unter dem namen der pandemie bekämpfung
eine politik der gebrochenen versprechen
und der überzogenen grundrechts
einschränkungen auch fdp und linke heute
offensiv und mit spitzen nach allen
seiten ihren berlin sprechen sprechen
die grünen ja davon sie wollen aus
unserer hauptstadt ein bullerbü machen
ich habe mitunter den eindruck dass
bullerbü auch ihr leitbild sein könnte
für die zukunft unseres
industriestandorts eine ländliche
dorfidylle mit subventionierten
lastenfahrrad die frage ist ganz einfach
linke oder lindner ich will zum schluss
gerne den satz von christian lindner
abgewandelt wiederholen es ist besser
gut mit der linken zu regieren als
falsch mit linda zu regieren heute
nutzten alle die gelegenheit noch einmal
alle wahlkampf botschaften loszuwerden
für die entscheidende frage wer wird
königsmacher für wen ist noch keine
antwort in sicht
dann bringen wir andrea maurer noch mit
dazu aus unserem zdf hauptstadtstudio
die das heute genau beobachtet hat halo
andrea ja wir haben es gesehen angela
merkel hat ihr politisches gewicht für
armin laschet in den wahlkampf geworfen
heute im parlament wie ungewöhnlich ist
sowas ja
es ist ungewöhnlich vor allem in diesem
wahlkampf bei dem die kanzlerin ja zum
ersten mal für einen möglichen
nachfolger werden muss und bislang nicht
durch werben für armin laschet nach
vorne getreten ist erst vor einer woche
hat die kanzlerin sich ja in den
wahlkampf eingemischt als die olaf
scholz die merkel sie kennen mich raute
quasi entzogen hat er dürfe sich nicht
auf sie berufen wenn er ein bündnis mit
der linkspartei nicht ausschließt heute
im parlament nun setzt merkel den ton
der auch die darauf folgende debatte
bestimmen wird die wahl als
richtungswahl entweder oder maß und
mitte mit armin laschet oder eine
regierung mit spd und grünen die die
linksparteien kauf nimmt auffallend
heute auch andrea die anti linksrutsch
rhetorik sage ich mal manche sagen auch
kampagne der union hat das parlament
erreicht führt auf der einen seite zu
web auf der anderen seite zu schärfen
kann man sagen wie da die wirkung ist
ja die wirkung ist würde ich sagen dass
dieser wahlkampf inzwischen ein harter
lagerwahlkampf geworden ist zwischen
denen die nach der wahl koalitionen
schmieden könnten das hat sich heute in
der debatte vor allem daran gezeigt dass
im grunde genommen alle versuchen
wählerinnen und wähler zu mobilisieren
solche schreckensszenarien das
schreckenszenario von union und fdp ist
das linksbündnis das schreckenszenario
der grünen ist das weiter so das
schreckenszenario der linken ist
christian lindner nur die spd hat in dem
sinne kein schreckensszenario olaf
scholz immerhin vizekanzler der jetzigen
regierung versucht es eher mit der
botschaft weiter so aber anders da olaf
scholz ein bündnis mit der linkspartei
mit hoher wahrscheinlichkeit vor der
wahl nicht mehr ausschließen wird ist
davon auszugehen dass es dass union und
fdp auch in den nächsten 18 tagen ihnen
damit quälen werden dass uns also dieses
thema erhalten bleibt und damit auch
weitere polarisierung und dann gucken
wir noch auf den kleineren parteien
insbesondere auf die die sich gerade
warm laufen um nach der wahl so was wie
zünglein an der waage zu sein wie hat
sich das heute im parlament gezeigt
welche koalitions achsen waren daraus zu
machen
ja das war heute vor allem muskelspiel
politisches muskelspiel der kleineren
parteien die linkspartei nutzte die
debatte um rot rot grün gerade maximal
als wahlkampfbühne auf die sie es ja
selbst aus eigener kraft in letzter zeit
eher nicht geschafft hat die partei
dümpelt bei 6 bis 7 prozent
heute klares werben in richtung spd und
grünen für gemeinsames regieren die
botschaft die themen die euch wichtig
sind nämlich soziales und klimaschutz
die findet ihr auch bei uns
bemerkenswert war auch der auftritt von
christian lindner dessen partei allein
an der waage sein könnte er erinnerte
scholz daran dass die stärkste kraft
nicht immer den kanzler stellen muss und
kann er kokettierte also auch mit dem
jamaika bündnis das eher 2017 hat
platzen lassen und will damit
möglicherweise den preis bei
koalitionsverhandlungen für seine partei
in die höhe treiben sowohl bei
rot-rot-grün als auch bei baker als auch
bei der ampel haben ja auch die grünen
ein wörtchen mitzureden von denen
allerdings heute kein werben in
irgendeine richtung außer für sich
selbst interessante analyse andrea
maurer berlin herzlichen dank dafür
jetzt ein ganz anderes thema hier die
taliban haben heute ihr
regierungspersonal für afghanistan
vorgestellt der eher wenig bekannte
mullah mohammed hassan zsak und wird
premierminister er gilt als gemäßigter
taliban verhältnisse was man von diesem
herrn hier nicht sagen kann sie reyhani
das einzig auffindbare foto von ihm
stammt von der fahndungsliste des fbi
er steht dort als einer der
meistgesuchten terroristen
man findet ihn künftig im
innenministerium kabul und zwar im
ministerbüro viel vertrauen bei denen im
land die sich versteckt halten weil sie
um ihr leben fürchten müssen dürften die
neuen machthaber damit nicht gewinnen
der druck auf die internationale
gemeinschaft bleibt enorm gerade ihnen
zu helfen über
34.000 menschen aus afghanistan haben
die usa via stein in der pfalz
ausgeflogen bei der bundeswehr waren es
rund 5000 menschen wer genau das ist
dazu gibt es viele unterschiedliche
zahlen und angaben mit denen bereits
kräftig politik gemacht wird und polemik
es lohnt sich deshalb die zahlen mal im
detail anzuschauen benjamin schikowski
[Musik]
bisher sind aus afghanistan
248 ehemalige ortskräfte nach
deutschland gekommen sie haben 916
familienmitglieder mitgebracht
ortskräfte sind menschen die in
afghanistan direkt für deutsche
regierungs organisationen gearbeitet
haben die aus kräfte genießen in
deutschland für 90 tage besonderen
schutz brauchen erstmal keinen
asylantrag
die zahl der in deutschland
aufgenommenen ortskräfte es in den
vergangenen wochen nochmal gestiegen das
hat vor allem drei gründe erstens es
sind einige menschen auch über den
landweg gekommen der weg führte über
pakistan und hat einige zeit gedauert
zweitens viele afghanen sind mit dem us
militär auf der us basis in ramstein
gelandet auch darunter waren auch kräfte
aber auch 90 menschen die nun in
deutschland einen asylantrag stellen das
brauchen die ortskräfte ja nicht und
drittens werden viele unterlagen erst in
deutschland richtig begutachtet es wurde
also erst jetzt geprüft ob jemand
wirklich als deutsche orts kraft in
afghanistan gearbeitet hat und deswegen
besonderen schutz genießt
insgesamt sind in den vergangenen wochen
4921 menschen aus afghanistan nach
deutschland gekommen neben den orts
kräften und ihren familien sind das vor
allem auch bürger anderer staaten die
deutschland mit ausgeflogen hat und
menschen die zum beispiel weil sie
deutsch sprechen oder für andere
organisationen gearbeitet haben mit
ausgeflogen wurden und deren
berechtigung hier zu leben nun geprüft
wird
nach offiziellen angaben sind darunter
auch 20 sogenannte
sicherheitsrelevante personen das sind
zumeist menschen die aus deutschland
abgeschoben wurden und im durcheinander
der evakuierungen wieder eingereist sind
auch deren aufenthaltsberechtigung wird
nun überprüft
überprüft wird auch die reaktion der
bundesregierung die ja komplett
überrascht wurde von dem was sein
afghanistan geschah und ihr langes
warten bis es dann irgendwann zu spät
war im neuen bundestag wird es wohl
einen untersuchungsausschuss geben heute
hatte der verteidigungsausschuss das
thema auf der tagesordnung und die
verteidigungsministerien dazu in seiner
sitzung thomas reichardt zeigt wie nahe
die überstürzte evakuierung immer noch
geht sie hat es geschafft aus
afghanistan in gedanken aber ist sie
immer noch dort bei denen die sie
zurücklassen musste bei ihrer
dramatischen flucht als kabul feld
schlägt pathoni teichmann sich mit einer
freundin durch zum flughafen dort fallen
schüsse ein teil der menge vor den toren
flüchtet sie bleibt bin einfach so schön
die leute rein gegangen oder einer
geschützten satz die rufen mich
habe ich geschafft was sie rettet ist
ihr deutscher pass was sie erschreckt
ist die lehre in der bundeswehr maschine
es ist der erste evakuierungs flug wir
waren in einen riesigen flugzeug nur
sieben leute in dieser zeit wo ich
wusste dass da stehen tausender die
richtig in gefahr sind auf ihrem laptop
hat sie ein video aufgenommen am
flughafenzaun
[Musik]
nur 8 von 30 mann hätten es inzwischen
aus afghanistan geschafft sie ist
überzeugt deutschland hätte viel mehr
menschen retten können hat das
auswärtige amt hat die bundesregierung
also zu wenig getan im zentrum der frage
ein brisanter bericht über den das zdf
vor gut einer woche zuerst berichtet
das hamburg glaubhafte hinweise erreicht
dass bereits am freitag dem 6 august die
botschaft in washington das auswärtige
amt gewarnt hat in einem vertraulichen
bericht dass die vereinigten staaten
jetzt mit vorbereitungen für eine eigene
kurios operation beginnen eine kopie des
schreibens mit den warnhinweisen ging
auch an das verteidigungsministerium
dieses papier lag erst mal ein
wochenende unter anderem im
verteidigungsministerium erreichte erst
mittwochs drauf den im urlaub
befindlichen generalinspekteur
wertvolle zeit verspielt worden so die
opposition um mehr menschen aus
afghanistan zu retten doch anträge von
grünen und fdp heute im bundestag über
die afghanistan versäumnisse zu
debattieren lehnen union und spd ab das
sei nicht nötig übrigens hat herr maas
auch die haltlosen vorwürfe dass das
auswärtige amt warnungen ignoriert hätte
sehr ausführlich widerlegt zusammen mit
den organisatoren der kabul luftbrücke
versucht habe ich man inzwischen selbst
menschen aus afghanistan heraus zu
helfen jetzt mal dass ich darüber rede
für mich dieser leute sind nicht nur
nummer die sind gesicht die sind
gesichter die dort sind besonders die
junge mädels mit wem ich gearbeitet habe
die sind mit diese ideen von demokratie
von der freiheit groß geworden und jetzt
lassen wir die einfach dort es bleibt
nicht mehr viel zeit sagt sie noch und
das die bundesregierung sie bislang nur
wenig unterstütze
und jetzt in der sendung eine ganze
reihe von wichtigen nachrichten zum
thema corona mit gundula der bundestag
hat dem aktualisierten
infektionsschutzgesetz zugestimmt damit
müssen beschäftigte in
pflegeeinrichtungen in kitas und in
schulen ihren arbeitgebern auskunft über
ihren corona impfstatus geben außerdem
wurden zusätzliche kennzahlen zur
beurteilung der pandemie lage in
deutschland beschlossen künftig sollen
nicht mehr nur die sieben tage inzidenz
entscheidend sein die heute leicht auf
83,8 gesunken ist auch
krankenhauseinweisungen werden stärker
berücksichtigt diese hospitalisierung
rate liegt laut lka aktuell bei
1,69 das heißt je 100.000 einwohner
wurden innerhalb einer woche im schnitt
1,69 corona patienten in kliniken
aufgenommen jedes bundesland soll für
sich definieren wann kritische
schwellenwerte überschritten werden
knapp zwei monate nach der
flutkatastrophe im westen deutschlands
hat der bundestag einen hilfsfonds für
die opfer beschlossen in den nächsten
jahren sollen rund 30 milliarden euro
für den wiederaufbau bereit stehen für
privathaushalte und unternehmen sowie
zur wiederherstellung der infrastruktur
um firmenpleiten abzuwenden soll zudem
die antrags pflicht für insolvenzen
ausgesetzt werden das gesetz dem der
bundesrat noch zustimmen muss sieht auch
eine bessere warnung der bevölkerung bei
ähnlichen ereignissen vor der bundestag
hat außerdem einen rechtsanspruch auf
ganztagsbetreuung in grundschulen
beschlossen über die finanzierung hatten
sich bund und länder erst gestern abend
im vermittlungsausschuss geeinigt jedes
kind das ab 2026 eingeschult wird soll
in den ersten vier schuljahren anspruch
auf einen ganztagsplatz bekommen der
bund unterstützt den ausbau mit 3,5
milliarden euro zudem will der bund für
den betrieb der ganztagsplätze mehr als
bislang zugesagt bei steuern 1,3
milliarden euro pro jahr
die eu-kommission hat beim europäischen
gerichtshof finanzielle sanktionen gegen
polen beantragt hintergrund ist der
andauernde streit um die polnische
justizreform warschau halte an der
disziplinarkammer zur bestrafung von
richtern fest so brüssel und verstoße
damit gegen die eu-regel der
unabhängigkeit der justiz polens
regierung hatte aber bereits die
abschaffung der umstrittenen kammer
angekündigt lässt allerdings noch
altfälle abarbeiten
in brasilien haben am heutigen
unabhängigkeitstag
zehntausende gegner und anhänger des
rechtsgerichteten präsidenten ball
szenario demonstriert golzow naro selbst
hatte zu den kundgebungen für seine
person aufgerufen auch um gegen den
obersten gerichtshof zu protestieren der
gegen ihn ermittelt wegen des verdachts
der verbreitung von falschinformationen
zugleich mobilisierte die opposition
ihrer anhänger umfragen zufolge könnte
bolts naro die wahlen im nächsten jahr
gegen seinen kontrahenten ex präsident
da silva verlieren
rund um münchen ging heute nicht mehr
viel die a8 die a92 überall gesperrte
fahrbahn überall stau
umweltaktivisten hatten gleich mehrere
protestaktionen gestartet ein zeichen
wie erbittert die diskussion geführt
wird um die mobilität der zukunft das
ist das thema der internationalen
automobilmesse iaa die sich nicht mehr
nur als auto show sieht aber auch noch
nicht genau sagen kann wohin der weg
denn nun führt klar ist wird für uns
alle neu und herausfordernd und
deutschlands autokonzerne von deren
wohlergehen in diesem land ja einiges
abhängt müssen sich fragen lassen ob sie
gerade für die große menge der
kleinwagen käufer das richtige angebot
haben peter meyer und alexander pohl
berichten
der schöne schein er will gehegt und
gepflegt werden frisch poliert
präsentieren die deutschen
autohersteller auf der iaa ihre elektro
modelle die botschaft wir haben
verstanden die politik nimmt diese
nachricht dankbar auf lobt sich dafür
ein zwölf jahre altes versprechen fast
eingelöst zu haben und wir haben uns ja
im jahr 2009 das ziel gegeben dass wir
bis ende 2020 eine million
elektrofahrzeuge auf den straßen haben
wollen wir haben's mitte
2021 erreicht ich finde wenn man eine
prognose von über von vor über zehn
jahren nimmt dann ist das immer noch
fast ziel erreichen nicht erreicht
hingegen werden viele künftige kunden
mit einem listenpreis von weit über
60.000 euro ist etwa der elektro suv x3
von bmw für die meisten unerschwinglich
und auch der vollelektrische mercedes
einen mittelklassewagen wird kaum
billiger zu haben sein experten
verweisen auf milliarden an
entwicklungskosten die die konzerne erst
verdienen müssen
luxusklasse an verkaufen dort die
fahrzeuge auch mit mit einem hohen
ergebnisbeitrag und können darüber im
prinzip die investitionen finanzieren um
auch in die breite masse zu kommen wenn
dieser breiten masse sind die
europäischen hersteller bislang nur
spärlich vertreten auch unternehmen wie
volkswagen das den anspruch autos für
jeden zu produzieren quasi im namen
trägt doch auch hier in der
kompaktklasse sind elektroautos alles
andere als ein schnäppchen
so kostet der vw id3 mindestens 35.000
euro renault verlangt für den kleinwagen
sowie knapp 30.000 ändern wird sich das
wohl erst in ein paar jahren wir haben
das ganze auch mal in unseren prognosen
und simulationen unserem lehrstuhl
erarbeitet und da sieht man ganz klar
dass mitte 2000 der mitte der 2020er
jahre elektrofahrzeuge nicht mehr teurer
sein werden als verbrennungsmotors
betriebene fahrzeuge weil genau dann die
staatliche förderung für elektroautos
voraussichtlich ausläuft drängt die zeit
für die deutschen hersteller klar ist
die nachfrage nach elektroautos ist
grundsätzlich da während die zahl der
neuzulassungen im august um ein viertel
auf 193 1000 pkw sank stieg der anteil
der e autos mit fast 28 prozent auf
einen neuen höchstwert wenn die
deutschen hersteller die nachfrage nach
günstigen elektroautos nicht befriedigen
können werden es andere tun so die
meinung von experten die konkurrenz etwa
aus china aber scheint den hiesigen auto
chefs keine angst zu machen natürlich
beobachten wir dass die chinesischen
hersteller machen und wir werden wie
immer bei wettbewerbsbeobachtung
eventuell darauf reagieren eventuell
könnte das zu spät sei
von der autoindustrie hängt viel ab in
deutschland frank bethmann verpasst sie
da eine epochale chance oder läuft es
alles in allem eigentlich ganz so rund
na ja es läuft schon ein bisschen besser
aber keineswegs grund weil wir eben über
china gesprochen haben weltweit
wichtigster absatzmarkt die deutschen
autobauer ja immer wieder betonen wenn
man dann aber schaue dass ich dort unter
den zehn e auto herstellern mit den
meisten zulassungen derzeit kein
einziger deutscher autobau befindet ist
es alarmierend innerhalb der letzten
drei jahre haben sich chinesische
autobauer nach vorne gekämpft die
hierzulande zwar keiner kennt die aber
teilweise kleine e autos für 5000 euro
für den massenmarkt bauen können diesen
segment sind die deutschen hersteller
also besonders anfällig ausgerechnet das
segment auch noch das für den
klimaschutz am wichtigsten ist und jetzt
sehe ich frank überall in deutschland
nach wie vor diese klassischen
tankstellen es gibt tatsächlich auch
mehr ladestationen aber weitem nicht
genug um wirklich eine wende zu schaffen
und wer keine möglichkeit zu laden hat
der wird sich natürlich auch keine autos
kaufen wie kommen wir denn aus dieser
zwickmühle raus ja vollkommen richtig
das schafft man nur wenn noch viel mehr
ladesäulen gebaut werden und zwar
schnell das musste heute auch die
bundeskanzlerin zu geben da müssen wir
eben besser werden sagte sie eine
million soll es mal geben aber knapp
50.000 sind es hierzulande erst und der
strom den man dort dann auch noch laden
kann er wird gut zur hälfte noch immer
aus kohle gas oder atomkraft erzeugt
also von ökostrom und klimaneutralität
sind wir an der stelle noch weit
entfernt viele fragen nach wie vor frank
bethmann frankfurt vielen dank
und hier jetzt nochmal nachrichten in
kürze mit gundula heute vor 70 jahren
nahm das bundesverfassungsgericht
unter seinem ersten präsidenten hermann
höpker aschoff seine arbeit auf als
lehre aus dem nationalsozialismus
schrieb man dem gericht in karlsruhe in
der noch jungen bundesrepublik deutlich
mehr kompetenzen zu als seinem vorgänger
in der weimarer republik dem
staatsgerichtshof bis zum vergangenen
jahr gingen fast
250.000 klagen beim
bundesverfassungsgericht ein die meisten
davon verfassungsbeschwerden
fast jedes zweite kind das im familiären
umfeld sexuelle gewalt erleidet wird von
seinem vater stief oder pflegevater
missbraucht das geht aus einer studie
der unabhängigen kommission zur
aufarbeitung sexuellen kindesmissbrauchs
hervor die familie werde dabei zu so
wörtlich dramatischen falle da andere
familienmitglieder den opfern oftmals
nicht glaubten oder halfen für die
studie wurden 870 vertrauliche
anhörungen und berichte ausgewertet
zum sport tennisspieler oscar otte hat
bei den us open eine sensation verpasst
der 28 jährige kölner unterlag im
achtelfinale dem wimbledon-finalisten
matteo bettine aus italien in vier
sätzen zu beginn des vierten satzes war
otte unglücklich gestürzt und konnte nur
unter großen schmerzen zu ende spielen
für die deutsche fußball
nationalmannschaft steht morgen abend
das dritte wm qualifikationsspiel
innerhalb einer woche an bundestrainer
hansi flick setzt gegen island auf einen
dritten sieg und muss allerdings auf
marco reus verzichten der dortmunder
leidet an knieproblemen und wird nicht
mit nach island fliegen beim
abschlusstraining mit dabei waren wieder
abwärts und robin goosens die beim 6 0
gegen armenien am sonntag nicht
mitspielen konnte
die internationale raumstation iss ist
ein riesiges forschungslabor in 400
kilometern höhe die astronauten dort
forschen in der schwerelosigkeit um die
wissenschaft auf der erde weiter zu
bringen noch ein paar wochen dann pflegt
einer dort nach oben der sagt astronaut
zu sein das hat schönheiten die kein
anderer job der welt bieten kann
matthias maurer hat für seine mission
den namen cosmic kiss gewählt es soll
eine liebeserklärung sein an den
weltraum und der mann der deutschland im
all vertritt hat dabei seine verbindung
zur erde nicht verloren in einen kleinen
ort im saarland so seine freitag
in oberthal chronisch im saarland ist er
der star der zu den sternen fliegt
matthias maurer ist hier um sich zu
verabschieden wo früher das alte
jugendzentrum war trifft er an die und
du hast seine besten freunde von
frühjahr erinnerungen an wilde partys
mit viel rockmusik sie werden ihm fehlen
ich werde natürlich auch meldungen aus
den wäldern von dort oben haben wir eine
hervorragende
telekommunikationsverbindungen internet
ist da also ich werde kontakt halten
ganz sicher ist so ist er matthias hat
irgendjemand
der
ein farbiger kugel ist
fünf jahre hat er sich vorbereitet auf
seine mission cosmic kiss
forschungs und überlebenstraining er
musste brände löschen bäume fällen in
höhlen überleben und wasser landungen
üben
in einem 200 kilo schweren raumanzug hat
er für einen außenbordeinsatz trainiert
dann muss man aussteigen aus der
raumstation und immer an zwei stellen
gesichert sein also mit mit halteseilen
wie so ein bergsteiger und im weltraum
ist das wirklich ganz ganz wichtig weil
wenn man den kontakt zur station
verliert dann ist man weltweit statt da
muss man verloren und das soll natürlich
nicht vorkommen
[Musik]
matthias maurer wird über 100
wissenschaftliche experimente machen 35
kommen aus deutschland er wird besondere
metalle testen mit eiscreme arbeiten und
mit staub und der frage nachgehen was
macht schwerelosigkeit mit dem
menschlichen körper
das immunsystem wird schwächer die keime
auf der station werden aggressiver wegen
der weltraum strahlen und all das wirkt
auf den menschlichen körper ein und so
können wir an den astronauten im
zeitraffer effekt erkennen welche
krankheiten oder welche abläufe im
körper passieren und können diese
übertragen um gewisse krankheiten auf
der erde dann besser zu behandeln
auf diesen ausblick freut er sich am
meisten den atemberaubenden blick auf
die erde seine kleidung ist übrigens
schon oben auf der iss und weil man dort
nicht waschen kann kommt ziemlich wieder
zurück
es geht eine alte versorgungs kapsel die
dann nicht wieder landet auf der erde
sondern die verglüht und wenn es dann
oben eine sternschnuppe gibt dann ist es
nicht immer was sehr schön ist es
vielleicht auch mal einfach nur die alte
wäsche von matthias
abschiedsparty jeder will noch mal
tschüss sagen ein schickes foto machen
ihr astro matthias bringt die heimat ins
all und vielleicht sogar sternschnuppen
made in salat
besondere sternschnuppen und ein
besonderer film jetzt nach uns auf den
nicht unbedingt noch hinweisen will
einer der anrührt mitnimmt und bewegt 37
grad ein hauch von leben es lohnt sich
auf jeden fall dabei zu bleiben
auch für die nachrichten die es hier
wieder um mitternacht gibt in unserem
heute journal update mit nazan guckte
mir in allen einen sehr angenehmen haben
[Musik]
ein schöner abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter
extremwetterereignisse neben weltweit zu
das hat jetzt kürzlich der weltklimarat
bestätigt sie haben zugenommen und
werden in der zukunft auch weiter
zunehmen das ist nun der rückblick auf
den sommer vor allem auf der
nordhemisphäre sehen wir hier über
europa war es zu warm und auch über
nordamerika dort wäre wurden ja bis
knapp an die 50 grad erreicht ja und
europa es war der wärmste sommer bisher
laut dem datensatz des kopernikus
programms bei uns ist es noch ruhig das
hoch verabschiedet sich aber allmählich
aus dem süden europas gelangt immer noch
warme luft zu uns aber wir haben im
westen ein tief und die kaltfront dieses
tiefs erreicht uns dann in den nächsten
tagen und bringt schauer und gewitter in
der kommenden nacht ist es ziemlich
ruhig es bildet sich in gewässernähe
nebel sonst klart es häufig auf und die
sterne funkeln temperaturen sinken dabei
auf 6 grad an den alpen und 15 grad ganz
im westen deutschlands ja morgen gibt es
verbreitet sonnenschein nur ganz im
norden einige harmlose wolken und die
temperaturen erreichen im südwesten die
höchste werte bis 29 grad aber häufig
liegen die temperaturen über der 25 grad
marke weniger warm ist es an der ostsee
mit 23 grad die kommenden tage werden
wechselhafter schauer und gewitter
nähern sich von westen her dann kann
auch starkregen dabei sein am donnerstag
vor allem im osten ganz viel
sonnenschein bis 28 grad und die darauf
folgenden tage bleiben größtenteils warm
und mit weiteren schauern gewittern
samstag allerdings nur noch bei 19 bis
24 grad ein schöner abend